JEEVANA HEGDE: Hi, everyone.
I'm Jeevana Hegde, a customer
engineer at Google Cloud,
and welcome back to
the Technical Guide
for Startups, where we are
creating a series of videos
for technical enablement
to start, build, and grow
your businesses successfully
and sustainably on Google Cloud.
In our previous
video, we deep dived
into streamlining your
application deployment.
And now we're onto
the fourth stop,
which is all about deploying
your microservices application
on Google Kubernetes Engine.
In this video, we're going
to go over understanding
microservices and
Kubernetes at a high level
and introduce you to Google
Kubernetes Engine, or GKE,
and understand a few of
its important features.
We will also be looking at a
sample e-commerce application
architecture and see
how it will be deployed
in the demonstration section.
We will finally end it
with a customer success
story of an actual
Google Cloud customer
and wrap up with some
actionable next steps.
So without any
further ado, let's get
right on to exploring the
Google Cloud platform together.
Imagine you and your teammate
have built out a fairly large,
complex application.
Now let's say you're
done making some changes
to your part of the
application, and your teammate
is still working on an
entirely different part
of the same application.
Wouldn't it be convenient
if you could just test out
your changes, or even deploy
to the main application
while your teammate continues
working on his part?
This sort of a
planning approach can
be taken if you build out your
architecture with microservices
as opposed to monoliths.
A monolithic application
is a single unified unit,
whereas microservices
architecture breaks it down
into a collection of
smaller, independent units.
Containerization is a
method of visualization
which separates the applications
and services at the operating
level.
And microservices uses
containerization to deliver
smaller, single-function
modules that work in tandem
to create more agile and
scalable applications.
And Kubernetes is excellent
for containerization.
Moving on to Kubernetes.
Kubernetes can be
summed up by two things.
One, it's an abstraction
over infrastructure.
What I mean by this is that,
when you install Kubernetes,
it handles the compute,
networking, and storage
for your user
workloads, so you don't
have to worry too much about
the underlying environment,
and you'll be able to
focus on your application.
And secondly, Kubernetes
uses a declarative format
to orchestrate its containers.
What we mean by that is that
you tell us what you want,
and not necessarily
how to create it.
Kubernetes runs a
control loop to ensure
that the current state
always matches the desired
state, as mentioned, in
your configuration files.
If it doesn't, Kubernetes
is smart enough
to know what steps to take
to keep them in alignment.
It might all seem
a little complex.
In fact, it is.
But that's where Google
Kubernetes Engine, or GKE,
comes in.
GKE is a managed service
for running Kubernetes.
GKE essentially gives you an
abstraction by providing you
with freedom with
some configurations,
and also manages
a lot of features
for your containerised
applications.
So when we say
managed, what we mean
by that is that it manages
your auto-repair, auto-upgrade,
auto-scaling, auto-provisioning,
and regional or
high-availability code plane.
It is also your amazing site
reliability engineering team.
We have two modes in GKE,
Standard and Autopilot.
Standard Mode is
where you configure
the cluster's underlining
infrastructure, giving you
the node configuration
flexibility.
And Autopilot Mode
is a step ahead,
where GKE provisions and manages
your cluster's underlying
infrastructure, including
nodes and node pools,
giving you an optimized cluster
with hands-off experience.
Now let's quickly jump
on to a demonstration
of configuring different
aspects of a GKE cluster
in both Standard
and Autopilot mode.
We start off by going to
the Google Cloud console.
This is the dashboard.
We then move to
the Navigation menu
and go to the Kubernetes Engine.
I suggest if you're not familiar
with the Google Cloud console,
please watch the Getting
Started on Google Cloud video
that we have for you in
the description box below,
just to get a quick run-through
of the Google Cloud console,
and then you can come back
and continue this video.
Here, we already have
a few of them pinned,
and we're going to go scroll
down and go to the Kubernetes
Engine.
Once you click on Kubernetes
Engine, this opens up.
You can then create a
cluster by clicking on Create
here or here.
Like we discussed, we have
Standard and Autopilot.
Let's start off with Standard.
Once you click on
Configure, if this
is your first time
creating a cluster,
you are given a quick tour
of what tabs to click on
and a brief overview
of what's in it.
I'm going to leave the
cluster name as it is,
and then I can
choose whether I want
a zonal or regional cluster.
I can also specify
if I want to give
the default node locations.
I can then choose my
control plane version,
whether I want it to be
static or release channel.
In release channel, every time
a new version is released,
the clusters are automatically
upgraded, unlike in static.
When I leave it
at release channel
and go here to
default-pool, you can
see that the auto-upgrade and
auto-release are blurred out.
This is because this
is automatically taken
care of in release channel.
Now instead, if I go back
and select Static version
and come back to
default-pool, you
can see that you can
choose whether you
want to auto-upgrade
or auto-repair or not.
Well, let me leave it
at release channel,
as it's a best practice, and
come back to default-pool.
Now I'm going to leave my node
pool name to default-pool,
as it is, leave the number
of node as well to 3,
change the minimum
number of nodes per zone
to be 1 and maximum to be
3, and just quickly look
at the other configurations
and leave them as it is.
I can either create my node pool
directly here, or go to Nodes
and change the
configurations of the nodes
that I want in my node pool.
I can choose from the
different families
here and change my machine type.
And maybe I want my machine
typed to have, let's say,
two vCPUs and 8 GB RAM.
And maybe I also want my disk
to have better performance,
so I'm going to change my
boot disk to make it SSD.
I'm going to quickly
look at the Security tab
here, leave them
all to as it is.
Look at Metadata in
case maybe I wanted
to add some Kubernetes label.
In cluster, I'm going to go to
the automation tab and Enable
Vertical Pod Autoscaling.
I could enable
auto-provisioning here as well,
but I'm going to
not do that now.
Move to the next tab.
Then here in Networking,
it's back to default,
which is my default network.
You'll learn more
about VPC creation
in the upcoming
videos, so stay tuned.
I can choose whether
I want my cluster
to be public or private.
Then you can see that
HTTP load balancing
has been enabled here.
This is for external
load balancing.
You'll learn, again, more about
this in the upcoming networking
video.
In the Security section
here, I'm going to, let say,
disable my shielded GKE nodes.
Then in Metadata, here it's the
cluster metadata, as opposed
to what we saw previously.
Then in the Features
section, you
can see a bunch of other
features which you can enable,
such as Cloud logging, Cloud
monitoring, Anthos service
mesh, and so much more.
And finally, I'm
clicking on Create.
For an actual
application, you don't
have to run through all
of these different tabs,
as the default values are
already chosen for you.
Of course, you can configure
them yourself as well.
And there you go.
We have a cluster
which is created.
For configuring an
Autopilot cluster,
it's much more straightforward.
As you can see,
in the tool here,
it only gives you one
thing that it talks about.
As you can see, a
few of those features
that we saw earlier
from the Standard
are already taken care
of in the Autopilot mode.
Again, I'm going to leave
the cluster name as is.
And the only option here is for
your cluster to be regional.
This ensures high
availability at all times.
You can choose a
region, of course.
And additionally, you
have some networking
and advanced options.
You can choose whether
you want your cluster
to be public or private.
Let me just drop down the
networking options here.
I can choose my
network here, whether I
want it to be the default one
or a network which I've created.
I can also choose
my node subnet.
There's also a possibility for
putting in different address
ranges.
If not, the defaults are taken.
Now I'm not going
to change anything
here, and hide my
networking options,
and go to Advanced Options.
This gives me a bunch
of different options
for the tabs which
we had seen earlier
in the Standard section.
I'm going to leave them all
as it is and click on Create.
And there you go, your Autopilot
cluster has been created.
Did you see how
much of a difference
there is simply between Standard
mode and Autopilot mode?
Now imagine you didn't
have GKE, and you
had to do all this yourself
only using Kubernetes.
Wouldn't it be so
much more harder?
Moving on to my favorite
section of this entire video.
Whether your application is
a bow-wow doggy dog boutique,
or ouch, first aid please,
health care application,
you can deploy your
microservices application
on GKE.
For the purpose of
this demo, we'll
be sampling an
e-commerce application
with a simple and
straightforward name.
Let's call it Online Boutique.
This sample application has
gotten 11 microservices.
Let's quickly look
at the architecture
so we get a clear
picture of what
our application looks like.
As you can see, it's
got a payment service,
an email service, the frontend
service, a separate product
catalog service, and so on.
My point being, the
application is broken down
and makes the maintenance,
debugging, scalability
so much more easier.
In this application, the
users access the website
through the internet, and they
reach the frontend service.
They can then browse the
items in the product catalog,
add them to their cart,
and then purchase them.
In the backend, the application
accesses a database.
Additionally, a
recommendation service
helps recommend similar
products, and so on.
This is the basic workflow
in terms of the architecture.
Now let's move on to
the demonstration.
As part of this demonstration,
let's look at three steps.
First, let's begin by
exploring the code briefly
from the GitHub repository.
Second, let's deploy
the application
on GKE via the command
line interface.
This, on Google Cloud,
is the Cloud Shell.
And finally, let's test out the
application once we deploy it.
Now quickly jumping
onto the first part.
I'm going to the
GitHub repository
of the online boutique store.
We can go to the
source file, have
a look at the
different microservice
files available here.
Then let's say I go
to the cart service.
Go to the source file here
and then click on Services.
We see the C# files here.
Let me go ahead and
open one of these,
the cart service C# file.
You can see the code here.
Similarly, you can go back and
look at these C# files to find
the code respectively
in the microservices.
We also have a few Node.js,
Python, and Java files.
This very simple and
short run through
was essential so we get
an idea to understand how
the code has been broken down.
Now that we have this
in place, let's go ahead
and deploy this
application on GKE.
You can deploy the application
through the Google Cloud
console, like how we
created a cluster earlier,
or we can use the
command line interface.
Here, let's go over the latter.
To do so, simply activate
Cloud Share and get started.
Start off by
assigning your project
ID to the variable project ID.
Now for this particular
project or project ID,
I'm enabling a few APIs.
Now let's go ahead and
clone our GitHub repository.
Fun fact, you have
something very
similar to your GitHub
repository on Google Cloud
itself.
This is called the Cloud
Source repositories.
You can store your code here
just as you do on GitHub,
so everything stays
on the platform.
Now let's go ahead and
create our cluster.
As we already discussed, we can
do this either in the Standard
mode or Autopilot mode.
Here let me go ahead and
use the Autopilot mode.
Once we've created it, we then
deploy our sample cluster.
Now let's ensure that
all our parts are ready.
Once they all show
that they're running,
we can pick the
external IP address
so we can access
the website and try
buying an item through
the application.
Now let's enter the external
IP address and test it out.
Yay, we have our website now.
Now we can scroll through
and browse through items.
Let's add this watch
to the cart and see
some product recommendations
which I might like.
OK, great.
Let's also add this top now.
And as we can see, this
e-commerce application
works perfectly.
And that brings us to
the end of this demo.
Now let's look at a
real-world Google Cloud
customer who benefited from
the Google Kubernetes Engine.
Meitu is a popular photo
editing application
which is a leading image
processing and social media
platform in China driven
by artificial intelligence.
GKE helped Meitu to
simplify the workflow
and reduce the
operational costs by 44%.
GKE's autoscaling
features allowed
them to use small machines
with a high bandwidth.
GKE gave the customers a
very high rendering speed
of just a few seconds,
which improved the customer
experience and made
customers come back to them.
Additionally, Meitu uses
Anthos to deploy and manage
containers all over
the world, BigQuery
to analyze user behavior and
get more accurate user insights,
and Firebase, which helps
them reduce the split testing
time to 50% so that
engineers can roll out
new features faster and
gain bigger market share.
The Senior Vice President
of Meitu talks about some
of the numbers here,
which I mentioned earlier.
They were also able to automate
their infrastructure management
and be much more productive.
Hopefully, that gave
you a bit of a nudge.
So when are you getting started
on the Google Cloud platform?
If this video interested
you to learn more
about containerization, GKE,
Autopilot versus Standard
and when to use which, don't
forget to check the suggestions
we have for you in the
description box below.
And that brings us to the
end of the fourth stop, which
is the GKE video.
In the next video, you will
learn more about the Compute
Engine, and you'll be learning
how to configure Compute Engine
instances.
You will also be doing a
sample application deployment
and end it with a
customer success story,
just like we did in this video.
So stay tuned if you're
looking into deploying
your applications on
virtual machine instances.
Don't forget to
like and subscribe
to our YouTube channel.
Hit the like button
to stay up to date
and receive notifications
every time we post a new video.
Bye for now, and we will see
you very soon in our next video.